all right let's go to sasha in carson
city what's up how are we doing
hey dr john it's so good to talk to you
you too hey did i say your name right
sacha sasha got it
beautiful beautiful name all right so
what's up how can i help
oh my goodness well how much time do you
have i have 11 hours
go this is a special podcast edition
um okay so i reached out to you all a
huge fan by the way
love all the ramsey personalities love
your show
thank you um reached out because i heard
from my mom recently
she had a request of my husband and i
to help her open up a a credit union
account
and this is um special for people who
it's a credit union who
caters to people in the military okay so
are you in the military my my husband is
in the military okay yes
and um so by sort of default she would
be able to benefit from
what the credit union has to offer so
she reached out to me
kind of out of nowhere asking if
we were a member and couldn't help her
open an account
is that a little bit shady i think
is that normal okay for me it's i
my knee-jerk reaction was oh
what i
i was a little i mean that sounds like
when i used to ask people
to be my girlfriend in middle school and
their first reaction was
so yeah been there on the other side of
that one sasha thanks for kicking me
while i'm down
okay yeah started to bring that back no
it's good so
why don't you trust your gut
i do i do trust my gut my my real
struggle is
you know how do i kind of i guess reject
her request and i know it's not going to
go well i'm
feeling a little guilty and a little
petty about it
but my deep down just does not feel
right
okay so here's what stinks man
parents often have the problems and
kids are forced to solve them right
that sounds like an old line check out
the hook while the dj revolves it that's
right that's that old line
your parents have the problems right and
kids have to solve them
and that i hate that because it should
not be that way parents should be mature
and grown up
and ethical and honest and they're just
a lot of times not
and so here's what's awesome about this
call
i could tell you're really smart and
you're kind
and you're honest
and so it's it's nice it sounds like me
very well but
no the fact that your first your first
thought when asked to do something from
somebody that you want to please
and that you want to respect and honor
and they ask you to do something that's
a wee bit shady
that is using a military benefit for
their
their good right your first thought was
no i might do that right it wasn't yeah
let's see how we can gain the system for
you
um here's what sucks about boundaries
you've got to draw them and you can't
hold the outcome
you can't be responsible for the
consequences of your boundaries
and so you're going to feel guilty
you've already said it
but it's your mom acting immature and
not being honest
right yeah and yeah here's what i'd
rather you do
i would rather you hold a strong
boundary
trust yourself because you're right hold
the boundary and grieve the loss of the
mother that you fantasize about
then you know
bend the rules here and then not be
forced to
like not be forced to deal with the
reality
your mom's using you your mom's using
your husband
right yeah yeah
yeah definitely i mean you said a couple
times the word boundaries and
that's really the underlying issue
there's been a number of times where
especially in like a financial
situation there's been some boundaries
that have been kind of
a little watery or muddy and so that's
really why i'm just you know if it were
maybe a good friend and
the rules applied i would seriously
consider it but
just we haven't had the best like
boundaries when it comes to finances
so how old are you um i am about to be
40.
okay and how long have you been married
um let's see it's been about seven
months now
oh wow so you're in it now okay is this
first marriage second marriage
first marriage we are also about to have
our first baby
congratulations okay so listen
it is the i can't tell you how important
it is
that you and your brand new husband
go somewhere get together and
write out on paper your boundaries for
your new relationship
your marriage and you're about to be
parents
if you thought mom was shady before oh
man
it's about to get awesome okay yeah
i mean some of that some of that is
definitely coming up and i i promised
myself i didn't want to
call here and bash her you know she's no
no she's obviously done the best she can
absolutely it's not a bashing it's a
it's a it's an honest declaration
right okay and there's a difference
between saying
i hate you you're an idiot you're a
[ __ ] and
you are not good with money and i can't
allow that into my new young family
yeah right one is dishonoring and
gossipy
and just trashing somebody to make you
prop you up and make you feel better
one is calling a spade a spade
right yeah there's a lot of people in my
life that i love dearly that i would
never hire right
a lot of folks that i talk to somewhat
regularly that make me laugh so hard i
don't know if my guts will ever work
again
that i would not leave my kid with right
right
so it doesn't have to be mutually
exclusive you do have to be wise
and here's the thing if you're not wise
and you choose to
duct tape over relationship issues
you're on a bullet train towards
resentment
yeah i can definitely i when i imagine
saying yes or
kind of giving in i i do feel that sort
of resentment like okay well i'll help
you with this but like
where were you at the baby shower and
like why can't we just talk about the
baby coming and
why does it have to be about a bank
account you know yeah
um it may be it may be that she wants to
open a bank account so she can put money
into it for your kid
right who knows who knows probably not
but it's fun to dream right
um here's the thing you're wise
and you're a good person so i tell you
that to tell you trust yourself
and you live in a world where women are
told don't trust your intuition
i'm telling you to trust yours and trust
your new marriage
and trust that impulse that says that's
not a good idea
and then get some get some time away
with your husband
plan and dream write down these
boundaries
and then hold them firm and then also be
loving to your mom too
and what's that mean that means be clear
and direct and not passive aggressive
yes yeah right go to coffee with her
or if she's too far away and just
talking on the phone sounds like you're
all living somewhat in the same area
go to coffee with her and say hey mom
i'm not gonna i can't use military
benefits
for somebody who's um not like
who doesn't apply they don't apply to i
can't do that i'm not gonna do that
well i think i'm not mom we're not doing
that
okay yeah you can go get your own
checking account or your own
credit union account when you want to go
get a credit union account
i'm not gonna do that yeah and then you
move on to the next thing
and if she chooses to throw a temper
tantrum on that that's a decision that
she's making
not that you made right that's true
yep and it's coming times a thousand
why don't you let me see my baby i want
to come see my grandkid it's my
grandbaby why don't y'all just go out
and i'm gonna hey i'm gonna got a new
boyfriend i'm gonna bring over to
whatever the thing is right
right right get those things down now
all right yeah that's a good idea okay
you what you want has value
the right things are the right things
and i you're gonna have to practice
holding those boundaries and here's
what's hard about boundaries
it takes so much energy and courage to
lay them out there
that we want everyone to just honor them
like it was so hard to build this
fence why why'd you knock it down or
why'd you keep bashing your head against
it
or why are you throwing things over it
at me trying to make it my fault that i
wanted to keep my family safe
always remember the the practice of
developing boundaries is hard
the practice of building boundaries and
setting them up is really hard
and then when people try to knock them
down it hurts
all of that is part of boundaries it is
always in the short term easier just to
be like all right whatever dude it's
easy
whatever and it always comes back to
bite you
always comes back to bite you you're
awesome sasha congratulations on new
marriage
thank your husband for his service for
our country
enjoy being a mom it's going to be
awesome and
man build those boundaries